PAUL RASHIDI: Hello.
I'm Paul Rashidi, a
Developer Programs Engineer
on the Google Cloud Platform.
I'm extremely passionate about
Compute Engine and mobile apps.
So not too long
ago, I started work
on some applications
that use both.
I realize there are probably
other developers out there
wanting to do something similar,
so I recently open sourced
a sample app.
I'm going to show
a demo of the app
and then briefly talk about
the process of building it
in Android Studio.
The readme file included
with the sample app on GitHub
explains how to deploy
the app for yourself
so you can get it running
on your own Android device.
First the demo.
The application is a simple one
that utilizes the CE API Java
client library to retrieve
project resource information.
It pulls information
about all active resources
from a developer project
you've previously registered.
As you can see, we start
with the login page,
where you can choose
a Google account.
We're going to select
my sample account.
This account listing is pulled
from the Google accounts
registered on the
Android device,
to avoid requiring the user
to re-enter their password.
Now that we've done that, the
code asks Android for an OAuth
2.0 token for that account, with
OAuth 2.0 scopes for Compute
Engine and Cloud storage.
I will accept this prompt,
and now the application
is able to retrieve
OAuth 2.0 access tokens.
As a reminder, an
OAuth 2.0 access token
is a time-limited
authorization string
that provides access
to Compute Engine
and cloud storage APIs
on behalf of a user.
Next, we type in a project
ID for the developer project
that the Google
account has access to.
This obviously needs to be
a project that is already
using CE or at least
has the API enabled.
This value can either be
the project name string
or the project number, which
we receive from the console.
We'll now click this
View Resources button,
and a new activity is invoked.
The app talks with the
CE API in the background
and loads the
resource information.
We can see that we have a few
instances and disks, as well
as the zones that our
project has access to.
We can also see
that this instance
has a scheduled
outage coming up.
This is actually an instance
I meant to delete earlier,
so we'll drill into
this and delete it.
Again, the app performs a delete
asynchronously with the CE API.
Pretty simple app.
For this app, we decided to
use the Android master detail
sample.
So if you run the
app on a tablet,
you'll notice it nicely combines
the first and second activities
together.
This is Android fragments
at work, but more about this
later.
Now let's look at the code.
In order to look
at the code, we're
going to need to retrieve it.
That's easy enough.
We're going to check out
the source code using Git,
and then import the project
via the import option
in Android Studio.
We'll select the
highest level project,
use the Gradle wrapper
option and import.
If you're having trouble
here, please see the readme
in the code repo for more
comprehensive instructions.
Now that we have the code,
the easiest way for us
to understand this project
is to look at the code
as it was committed.
You can see the
first few commits
are project wizard generated
code and are mainly
defining entries in Git ignore.
The structure is a bit different
from the Eclipse environment.
As you can see, we're excluding
the build directory, as well as
the idea and Gradle
hidden directories.
All these files should
be inferred from the main
build Gradle file.
So there's no need
to check them in.
We're also excluding
the lib directory,
since we're pulling in
our dependencies via Maven
vis a vis Gradle.
More on Gradle a little later.
For the project wizard commit,
I used all the defaults,
except that I chose
a minimum SDK of 11
so that I had Android
fragments available.
This allowed me to
use the master detail
sample as the basis of my app.
You don't have to choose
version 11 if you're
creating your own app
and don't want fragments.
But I like the
simplicity of the tablet
interface we saw earlier.
The next commit is a doozy.
It contains the addition
of the API interaction code
to the project.
All of our code that
uses the CE API is here,
since we need to keep network
calls off the user interface
thread.
You can see we basically
instantiate an API stub,
create a command, then
execute the command.
In the case of a
delete command, we're
going to make an
additional status call
and wait for it to complete.
In this commit, I also
snuck in the addition
of a login activity.
It's the sample
login activity that
can be created with a right
click in Android studio,
like this.
Finally, you will
notice a critical change
in the build.gradle
file in this commit.
If you aren't
familiar with Gradle,
then you could probably
get away with the fact
that it's the new preferred
way to define your builds.
This snippet is
specifically pulling
in all of our dependencies
by defining them
as Maven dependencies.
All of the Google client
library for Android jars,
as well as the surface
extension for Compute,
will be added to the project
because of these lines.
The snippet does use
Maven, but you're still
required to have downloaded some
libraries via the SDK manager.
Read through the
comments in the snippets
for the specific packages you
need to have fully updated.
The next commit has us
implementing the login activity
to use the Google
account credential.
This is an Android
aware credential
that will reuse Google
accounts on the device
and allow applications
OAuth 2.0 token access.
Finally, the last
interesting commit
is the implementation
of the resources list
to connect to the async
tasks we checked in earlier.
In this commit, we
adjusted the XML layout
files to display our resources
and updated the list and detail
fragments to display our
instances, disks, and zones.
That's about it for the code.
I'm really looking forward
to seeing some applications
on mobile devices that use
the Compute Engine API.
I appreciate your
time and would ask
that you star our
project on GitHub and/or
the video to indicate
they were useful.
Thank you.